Another way to look at the size of human genome instead of just counting
the number of letters it has, is to think about it in physical size.
Remember that's three billion base pairs that
takes up space, but how much space?
Well, let's imagine that a base pair is about the size of a light bulb.
>> Okay.
>> A light bulb is about 13 cm from tip to tip. And let's imagine that
like our base pairs we could stack our
light bulbs end to end, thirteen centimeters long each.
If we had three billion, we could get past the moon over 390,000 kilometers.
>> That's a lot but, let's get serious, Matt. This is a lot
bigger than a base pair. Isn't a base pair only about. 34 nanometers?
>> This is true. . 34 nanometers is actually very small, much smaller than a
lightbulb. But at three billion base pairs, three billion times 0.34 nanometers
is a billion nanometers and a billion nanometers
is exactly one meter long. Look at that.
>> Well, that's really long in the actual length. That's more than half of me.
>> I know, and actual length this is what actually what has
to fit inside your cell, but not just this. You have one copy
from Mom and you have another copy from Dad. You have two
copies of the human genome in every cell in your body. This together
is over two meters of DNA. That's taller than I am.
>> Wow.